there's something really appealing with
anything to ticking it apart and finding
how it works it's like seeing the world
through the eyes of a kid how does it
work you take it apart you figure it out
and we don't get to do that with phones
and computers because they're
inscrutable their black boxes but
something that's got gears and metal and
screws and things in it that is fully
powered by a little spring that's inside
of it that you can take apart and figure
out how it works I'm Samir Patel deputy
editor of Atlas obscura and we're in
midtown Manhattan at the aura logical
Society of New York hello okay Samira
Samira nice to meet you I'm Nick I'm
about to take a class in watchmaking so
I think we're gonna take a mechanical
watch movement and take the entire thing
apart and put the entire thing back
together I think it's gonna go super
poorly but I'm gonna do my best and
we'll see if I can not completely
destroy this watch movement my name is
Nicholas Medusa's I'm the president of
the horological Society of New York were
housed in the general Society building
on 44th Street the horological society
was founded in 1866 and is one of the
world's oldest continuously operating
watch making associations
today we are a 501 C 3 non-profit and we
focus on education education for the
public our mission is to teach as many
people as possible
everything about horology we're going to
teach her ology 101 and we teach the
basics of what makes a mechanical watch
tick so now we're going to take a look
at the tools that you have in front of
you yeah so the correct way to use these
screwdrivers is to hold them like this
and put your pointer finger on the top
and so what this does is it stabilizes
the screw the screwdriver
yeah and the tweezers are pretty similar
to the ones as you probably have at home
except that they're very sharp I have
stabbed myself with them before it's not
fun anytime you want to touch something
hold something down push something in
the movements instead of using your
finger we use the plastic points it's
good and of course the loop so the loop
is a magnifying glass you wear over one
of your eyes
okay so let's get into it
so the first step before taking a part
of the watch is letting the power down
it's kind of like a car if you're going
to work on the engine of the car you
would turn the engine off first right so
you're kind of gonna want to brace using
your pinky and then also get your
pointer in there yeah my fingers have
never felt so fat than they do right now
I knew basically how timekeeping works
but just to understand when you look at
the back of a watch or the inside of a
movement what all of these pieces are
and how they work in harmony that's
something I don't feel like you feel
until you actually take it apart and try
and put it back together
so I was trying to watch where you were
putting your fingers because holding the
thing is not necessarily the most
intuitive thing to hold multiple things
at once there are certain parts in watch
movements that require coordination like
putting a train wheel bridge back into
place
you need to line up three different
wheels at the same time each of those
wheels has a pivot that needs to be in
exactly the same place and so
watchmaking is not just putting things
together it's also practicing focusing
and kind of meditating and getting into
the right zone to be able to get things
back together again
inside the mechanical movement like
kissing the purple from the jewels but
you're very very close at this point did
it that's it just felt clicking yep the
experience of learning from Nick was
great because every time something
wasn't working he would come in
immediately and diagnose it it was often
something simple like I wasn't holding
the screwdriver straight he would say
tilt the screwdriver towards your head a
little bit and then the screw would fall
into place and I would stop slipping all
over the place it's clear he knows what
he's doing and he knows what the
pitfalls are that people run into when
they're learning how to do this my
favorite part was when you take the
balance wheel and the balance spring and
you dangle it and it's trembling in your
fingers and you set it down and you
bring your hand around and drop it with
your tweezers and the watch just springs
to life
perfect good job you get it that's it
thank calculations I did a great job
you've got a second career and launch
making if you ever want to make the
switch don't tempt me
I love teaching new students because
students come into the class and they
may be nervous and they may not know
exactly what they're gonna be doing and
getting them through the entire class to
the the very last step when they put the
balance wheel back into the watch and
they see the watch come to life it's
magical
I see a smile and come across their face
and it makes me feel good knowing that
I've taught them a little something
about her ology about mechanical watches
and it's just a good feeling at the end
of the day I really enjoy teaching
[Music]